[MUSIC PLAYING]
INTERVIEWER: Hello, everybody.
Welcome.
And mostly welcome to Edoardo,
who is here with us today.
He just shared with
me a very funny story
of his first
contact with Google.
So I thought it would be nice
to start by asking him to share
this story with everyone here.
EDOARDO NESI: Hello,
thank you for coming.
I was telling [? Marsha ?] that
the first-- the really first
time I entered the
internet, I was
told that I had to
start from Google.
So I wrote Google.
And then, I saw the
page, the home page.
And I said--
I was afraid.
Because I said, how much am I
going to pay to make it search?
[LAUGHTER]
I was waiting to see somebody
to say $1 for everything.
So I said-- then I
realized it was not--
yeah, that I didn't have to pay.
And so it was the
start, I mean, the start
of my internet experience.
INTERVIEWER: Cool.
Thanks for sharing that.
So we're here today to
talk about your new book.
And while I was reading
it, I really much
enjoyed the style and
especially this conversation
between Eduardo and Guido.
I don't know if the English
edition kind of like
reflects that as good.
But the Italian is
really interesting.
Because you really capture
two different styles.
And so here we are having a
textile entrepreneur from Prato
and an economist from Rome.
They're talking to each other.
And one thing that
I was wondering
is, how did that happen?
What's the genesis of the book?
How did you guys decide
to write a book together?
I can't think of two worlds
more different than that.
EDOARDO NESI: Well,
it's a funny story, too,
because we have common friends.
And they were in
the movie industry,
kept on telling him that he--
well, he should meet Edoardo.
And they kept telling
me, we should meet Guido.
And so since the start, we said,
we are not going to be friends.
You know?
And then, he was-- he's
not only an economist.
He is one of the greatest
private equity investors
in Europe.
He has been awarded
two or three times
as the best investor in Europe.
And so I said not really--
not my cup of tea.
And then, I met him.
And I found out a
very strange person.
I mean, for all his richness--
because Guido's very rich--
he's always worried about
how things are going
to go for the poorest people.
He is-- well, he's not
here, so I can talk freely.
I mean, he gives--
[LAUGHTER]
--he gives a lot of
money to a foundation,
to his own foundation
that helps children to be
cured of unknown illnesses.
And he's very Christian.
He is very devout.
And he's a nice person.
So when I started to hear
these things about him,
then I said, no, so maybe we
can start becoming friends.
And when we started
becoming friends,
we realized that we had--
we had the problem
with the way things
were going for our country.
And we shared completely
different beginnings
and completely different works
and futures and destinies.
But we were terribly
worried about the direction
that Italy was going to be.
If I can go on, I am--
I used to be a
textile entrepreneur.
We-- my family had a
textile business that
started before the World War.
And we were making
covers-- you know--
covers for-- because
at the beginning,
well, there was no central
heating everywhere in Italy.
You needed a cover to put on.
And then, we started
to make fabrics.
And when we started to make
fabrics, the war broke out,
and the Germans invaded Italy.
And we had a small company.
The heart of the
company were four looms.
The looms were very
big and very slow.
But they were our richness.
So they've always been with us.
But when the Germans
retired from Italy,
the very day they left
Prato, my hometown,
they bombed our looms.
They made them explode.
They destroyed them,
as they were destroying
everything that had
value for the people,
for the Italian people.
And so it was a
terrible blow for us.
I have to say that
in the coming years,
they helped us to
rebuild the company.
Because they were making
orders for our fabrics.
And there were very,
very good and very honest
customers for us.
But well, the beginning of our
relationship was not that good.
[CHUCKLES]
INTERVIEWER: All
right, so thank you.
This kind of leads into
the next question, which
is, what is the book about?
Like, OK, so if
I'm the bookstore,
and I'm considering
buying this book,
I'm a prospective reader here,
why should I get this book?
Why shall I read it,
especially from the point
of view of a US reader?
What should be particularly
interesting here?
EDOARDO NESI: Well,
there are a few reasons.
One is you get to know how
things went very well and then
very bad for the
fashion industry,
for the fashion system.
Our company, our
textile company,
was working for the
most important stylists
in the world.
You name it.
I mean, we were working
with all of them.
And we were delivering good
quality at a good price.
Because it's very difficult
to work with Giorgio Armani,
for example.
Because Giorgio Armani,
he makes personally
the choices of the fabrics,
because he's a very--
he doesn't-- he doesn't leave
a lot of space to his people.
But he's extremely good.
He's one of the few
stylists that really
knows something about fabrics.
And so we-- I mean,
we were working
at the highest level, in a way.
We were doing
fabrics for coating,
for jackets, and
not only in wool--
linen, cotton, everything.
We were very good.
This I want to state.
Because every time we discuss
how Italian textile system went
down, went to almost
bankruptcy, there is always
the problem with competition.
We didn't hold onto competition.
We couldn't face competition.
But it's a bit more
difficult to say.
It's different.
It is another kind of
competition then, maybe--
we'll go on with this.
So this one is the reason.
The second reason is why Italy
is not what it used to be.
It's not anymore
what it used to be--
how everything really
lost meaning and sense
in the production of well being.
Whatever happens in the United
States always affects Italy.
And the beginning of the book
is the Millennium celebration
by Bill Clinton in Washington.
And the end of the book
is the inaugural speech
of Donald Trump.
And the book tells also
the story of what--
of everything that happened
in the financial world
in those years and how the--
and how the-- all the
crises were faced in Europe
and in the United States.
I mean, it's a small
book, but it has inside
two stories which could not
be more different than one
from the other.
So I am the loser in the story.
And Guido is the winner.
I don't like to say that.
I mean, it's about--
it's how the Italian publisher
kept on talking about the book.
So at the end of the
book, I said maybe--
maybe that's the story.
Because I lost my
textile company.
And Guido is still one of
the most important investors
in Europe.
Another reason why you should
probably read this book
is that we discuss about
fast fashion, which
is this terrible
phenomenon that you
go through all these giants,
like Zara and the H&M.
And you go there, and
you buy something.
And you think that it's fashion,
because it looks like fashion.
It has the right colors.
If you see things
from 10 meters away,
it's a perfect imitation of what
fashion should look like today.
INTERVIEWER: I'm
wearing a Zara jacket.
EDOARDO NESI: Ah!
[LAUGHTER]
I forgive you.
INTERVIEWER: Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
EDOARDO NESI: But then,
well, let me tell the story.
One of these giants--
my daughter Angelica,
when she was very young,
she wanted to go there.
She said, babbo, you
have to take me there.
And when she says
this, I always do.
I mean, everything,
whatever she wants, I do.
So I even went into
this-- into the shop.
It was a fantastic
experience for me.
Because they came to us.
They wanted to buy our fabrics.
And they said, the
fabric is fantastic.
But we could not pay
15 euros per meter.
We can pay seven.
So do a seven euro
version of this fabric.
I said, this is impossible.
I mean, you're
choosing cashmere,
just to make an example.
And you want cashmere
for seven euros.
It's impossible.
OK.
So just to give you an idea of
how dealing with these people
works.
So we entered the shop,
and we see things.
And the shop is fantastic.
The music is fantastic.
The sales people were very good.
And then, you see the
stuff from 15 meters.
And you say, oh, it's good.
The colors are very good.
The buttons are--
and then, every step
you do, towards the
jacket or toward the coat,
you see there is
something wrong.
And then you touch it, and then
you see what the problem is.
But then you realize
that you are already
inside the idea of
blackmailing yourself.
Because you go there.
You say, this is a jacket,
and it costs 39 euro and 99.
Also, this thing-- you know?
39.99-- if you go
to another shop
and you buy something
better, it is 100 euro.
And then you say, I don't know.
Maybe I should save this
and have the same thing.
I mean, it's not as good--
I know it's not as good.
But it will work.
And it usually does for
two weeks, for three weeks.
The fourth week
you have it, then
you start to see button
losing, and there is a problem.
And then whenever you
wash it, you know.
I think you have
the same experience.
You realized it.
And then, you see how this
phenomenon really works on you.
You decide what to do.
You trick yourself in believing
that you are saving money.
But then, you start to realize
that Zara, for example,
is growing bigger and
bigger every year.
And his owner is
one of the most--
well, the richest
person in the country.
So somebody is
buying these things.
So you are not saving that much.
Because there is research
that says that, for example,
in Great Britain, every 20
days, you buy something.
So at the end of the year,
you've spent a lot of money
on things that are not
as good enough as you
should-- they should be.
It's the idea that
whenever you buy something,
you forget about the price.
And then you forget about
even that you bought it.
Because their fantastic system
is such that every week,
there is a new collection.
And it's real.
It's true.
Whatever they don't
sell, they discard.
It's sent away.
You know where.
Well, if you look at
the true cost, which
is the very interesting
documentary that
was made by Andrew Morgan,
you see where it ends up--
in the poorest
country where there
are mountains of
these discarded things
that were bought
and thrown away.
Or even they were unsold,
and so they were--
they followed the same destiny.
But they maybe went
into another way.
But this is one of the reasons
you should read the book,
because we discussed this.
And I know the subject.
Well, it's a sad story,
but I know the subject.
INTERVIEWER: Well, thank you.
So one of the most revealing
moments of the book for me
was the explanation that
quantitative easing,
that somehow worked in the US,
didn't really work in Italy.
And essentially, the money
stopped at the banks, right?
And it connected with the
thought that I always had was
how much easier it is
to borrow money here
with respect to Italy.
So it's always been shocking.
And I was wondering,
do you and Guido
think that there could have
been a way to actually make
it work in Italy?
EDOARDO NESI: Well, Guido
could answer better than me
to this question.
But anyway, the
problem is this--
quantitative easing was made
by the European Central Bank
to save easily Italy
from a terrible crisis.
You will remember that
Greece was in crisis.
And together with Greece,
after a few months,
Italy went in a
financial crisis so bad
that the spread between our
bonds and the German bonds
kept on rising.
And it had become
almost impossible
for the federal government
to issue new bonds,
because they were so
expensive that we should have
been bankrupt if that
phenomena could go on
for months and months.
So the European Bank
made the right decision.
The problem is that
we are in Europe.
And we love to think that we
are a big, single community
of different states.
The problem is that
we are very different,
and that Germany is so strong,
has such a strong economy,
such a strong state, that
sometimes the European politics
trying to help the poorest
country, like Greece,
like Portugal, like Italy,
like Spain, well, that hurts
the interest of Germany.
And so it's very difficult
to [INAUDIBLE] in a way
that everything is
good for everybody.
So we went into this--
the quantitative easing.
And the European Central
Bank started to create money,
to print money,
and to buy bonds.
But if you buy bonds from the
state, you help the state.
But this money, which is
billions and billions of euro
every month, it stops there.
It doesn't go to the people.
And it doesn't go
to the business.
It doesn't go to the
private companies.
And so there is a huge
creation of money.
And it doesn't go to the people.
And that's how it
works in Italy,
which is crazy, because
not going to the people--
the voters, for example,
they do not even
know that-- what is
going on in Italy.
What happened in
the States, I think,
is that whenever an economy
is based on consumption,
everything goes to the
consumer, because it's
interest for everybody.
In Italy, it didn't work out.
So we were inundated with money.
And we didn't see even
a single drop of it.
INTERVIEWER: Yeah.
That's kind of crazy
to think about it.
Yeah.
EDOARDO NESI: It's crazy.
It's crazy.
Because that ocean of
money really saved us
but saved the state.
In Italy, we are not so
sure that we are the state.
In Italy, we try to think that
the individual are one thing,
and the state is another--
very often in a fight, in
a cruel fight between them.
And so I think I--
did I answer the question?
INTERVIEWER: I'm still
just wondering, like,
was there actually a
way to make it work?
Was there a
possibility of getting
this money to the people
rather than stop at the bank?
EDOARDO NESI: This is the
question that is in the book.
And I asked Guido that.
So why is it so?
Why don't you help the economy?
Why don't you make it
possible for small companies
or for a small
business to have money
and to invest, to
buy new machines,
and to hire more people?
And he said that the Germans
are afraid of inflation,
which is funny, because
inflation is nothing in Italy.
And it has been nothing in whole
Europe for years and years.
But they are afraid
it could grow up.
You know, I have a
different approach to this.
Because when I was
young and Italy
was growing at the same rhythm
that China is growing now,
which is 7% per year--
in those years,
inflation is very high.
And so I grew up in a time and
in a place and in a country
where inflation has been
up-- you remember probably--
INTERVIEWER: I do.
EDOARDO NESI: --of more
than 10% every year.
And everything was going
on, was going perfectly.
So I'm not Guido.
Guido would be here--
would be perfect to
answer this question.
But I still think that a
little bit of inflation
is not very bad for a country.
INTERVIEWER: Well, I'm going
to switch a little bit here
and get maybe a little
bit closer to me
and to this audience.
So in the late
'90s or early 2000,
while you and many
other people in Italy
were sort of sinking with
the boats, we got out.
We took our wonderfully publicly
paid education from Italy
and came to the US, where
we thought we were going
to get more possibilities.
It's known under the
name of "brain drain."
And there's been a
lot of talk about it.
And a few of us went back,
but most of us stayed here.
Are we guilty, or
are we innocent?
What could we do
to give back now?
And why didn't you
make a similar choice?
EDOARDO NESI: Well, let's
start with the beginning.
You are innocent, and
you are making honor
to our country being here and
working as good as you are.
I mean, this is
extremely important
that the Italian image
is defended abroad
by people like you, or
many other people that
maybe are here, and they come
from different countries.
But in Italy, it is
even more important,
because the brain drain we had--
well, it's still going on.
Well, it's accelerating,
as a matter of fact.
But there is nothing you can do.
You have to make your own
choices, your best choices.
And then you have--
the problem is that
we live in a system
and in a country that not only
allows this but encourages
this.
We are encouraged to go out.
I mean, my son is studying
contemporary art in London.
My daughter is studying now
in Milan at the Polytechnical.
But in the next
few years, she will
start master's somewhere--
maybe in California, maybe
in England.
You have to go out.
This is not anymore
the time where
you can live a working
career in your country.
Let me say one little thing.
You know, my hometown,
Prato, it was and still
is the biggest textile center
in Europe, even in production
and in quality.
And it was possible that if
you wanted to make textile,
if you wanted to make
fashion, living in Prato
all your career was a--
was a fantastic choice.
Because that's where-- that
was the place if you wanted
to learn how to make
linen with Teflon or you
wanted to make Kevlar
with nylon and with wool.
That was the place.
Now, it's not that way anymore.
So even if you want
to make textiles,
you don't have to live
in Prato or in Italy.
Many of our best
technicians now work
in China or in other places.
So it's a big world.
And you are not--
you don't have to--
you are not guilty.
And you should never
feel guilty for this.
INTERVIEWER: And so why didn't
you make a similar choice?
EDOARDO NESI: Well,
it's a funny story.
I was a bit afraid of this.
Because I started very well.
Because I had the idea
that I wanted to come here
to attend in university.
And I was in a summer
session in '85 and '87.
I went to Harvard,
and I went to Cornell.
So I knew the system.
But then, you know, it was
the golden age for Prato.
And everything was
very la dolce vita.
It was la dolce vita.
And I was very young.
And I did not have not even a
friend that was coming with me.
And my family was
perfectly OK with the idea
that I stayed in Prato.
And so I had no strength,
no courage enough,
let's say, to come here.
INTERVIEWER: Maybe
it's the timing thing.
Just a few years made
a big difference.
EDOARDO NESI: Maybe.
Then I met Carlotta,
my wonderful wife.
And so the idea of coming
to America was finished.
[CHUCKLES]
INTERVIEWER: So in the most
recent part of your life,
you have been a politician.
And you have been a
member of the parliament.
We are coming out of a very--
well, coming out-- we're
probably not yet out
of a very interesting
political season in Italy.
Elections happen, situation
is very confusing.
We're still not clear on who's
going to govern in Italy.
But one thing that is
clear is that there's
this new 5 Stelle
movement that's
the fastest-growing party.
And one of the key
points of their program
is actually the
protection of "Made
in Italy" and the elimination
of the Europe tax.
And you touch both of
those things in your book.
And so I was wondering--
that must be feel--
feeling very close to you.
And are they getting
this right on this front?
Is that the solution?
EDOARDO NESI: Let me
start with the beginning.
After my book,
"Study of My People,"
won the Strega Prize,
many politician
seemed to start to think
that I was right on the fact
that you have to understand
how impossible it had become
for a textile company, or
even for every manufacturing
company in Italy, to survive.
And so they said, why don't
you enter in politics?
Why don't you candidate?
Why don't you
enter in the system
and try to give a
contribution and try to help?
That was very naive on my side.
Because I thought
it could be true.
So I entered in the parliament.
I was a candidate,
and I was elected,
and I went to parliament.
And I thought that
I could really
make a difference, which is,
in retrospect, even very funny.
[CHUCKLES]
Let me just tell you one thing.
The Chamber of Deputies
in Italy has 630 persons.
The Italian Senate has 315.
So when we elect the
President of the Republic,
we are 1,000 people.
So I know that in Congress,
you have so much less
of these numbers.
You know, you have many--
not-- I'm sure it's hard
for you to understand,
how is it possible
that 1,000 people are
needed to govern the country?
And then you see how
bad they govern it.
[LAUGHTER]
Maybe because there are so many.
I don't know.
But this 5 Stelle
phenomenon is something
I have to spend a few
minutes to tell you about,
because it's very funny.
So the creator of
this phenomenon
is a stand-up comedian.
No, you're laughing,
but it's true.
[LAUGHTER]
He was one of the most important
stand-up comedian in Italy--
was very good, very funny.
Then he started to say that
everything had to change.
And he started to
found this movement.
And they won the election.
After 10 years, they
won the elections.
And believe it or
not, the people
that are elected by this--
by this movement, they are not--
they are chosen online.
So they-- I see your expression.
But it's true.
OK, so you say you
want to be elected.
And you go in a particular site.
And you say that--
you present yourself.
You make a video.
And the people go there,
and they choose you.
And some of these people were
elected with 50 votes, 5-0.
So they are friends.
They voted for him.
And they were in a part of
the list that was elected,
because so many
Italians voted for them.
And they won the elections.
They went very well in the last
elections, and they won these.
And the people there,
they are usually
directed by a company in Milan
and by the stand-up comedian
that is still there.
And the last thing he said,
work is not important, he said.
[CHUCKLES]
You laugh.
And I laugh.
But it's what he said.
And the people voted for him.
They said the state should
pay the people to live.
He said it should
be 600 euro a month,
which, in dollar, is
$800, something like this.
INTERVIEWER: Yeah,
roughly, yeah.
EDOARDO NESI: And they won the
elections with this promise.
And now we are in the process
of making a government with a--
with the liga, the league,
which is a racist party,
which is a fascist party.
So then, well, this is
how Italy has become.
This is why this book
had success in Italy,
and I hope it will
have success here.
Because it's an
incredible story of how
one of the most fantastic
country in the world
really went down the sink.
But anyway, last thing to say--
"Made in Italy," the
movimiento, the 5 Stelle
say that we want to protect
the "Made in Italy."
Well, there is the percentage.
10% only of their elected
people have been working
a single day in their life.
The rest, 85% of the people--
because when you go
into the parliament,
you have to present
your declaration.
You have to say how much
have been making money.
85% of them have never worked.
They were students, or
they were in between jobs.
Or they were living
with their family.
And so when they
say in parliament
that they want to protect the
"Made in Italy," I always ask
them, what do you know
about "Made in Italy"?
What have you been doing for
"Made in Italy" personally?
What you know about this?
Well, maybe I should stop here.
[LAUGHTER]
Because I realize how emotional
I can become on the subject.
Because the problem is
that they should not win.
Somebody else should have been
an alternative for the people.
It should have been going to the
election and say, vote for me.
Don't vote for these people.
But it's another funny thing--
their promise of the
600 euros a month
has been understood
by the people.
So they read on--
and they watched
on television, they
saw-- they read in the
newspapers and online
that 5 Stelle won the elections.
So they went to the common and
say, give me the 600 euros.
So I said, what?
They said, they won.
We voted for them.
Give us the money.
Which is true, which is fine,
which is a good direction.
Problem is that they will not--
they will never be able
to make up this promise.
INTERVIEWER: All
right, so it's--
we're not doing much
better than before.
EDOARDO NESI: Well,
week after that, but--
week after that, I think.
INTERVIEWER: So let's go
to American politics now.
At the last minute,
you called Guido
pleading to cancel the book,
because you perceived that you
were inadvertently supporting
Trump based on his campaign
and inauguration speech.
So based on the past year
that Trump has been in office,
do you think he's
actually been able to make
any difference with
respect to the situation
of the middle class in America?
EDOARDO NESI: Well,
this is a funny story.
I follow the elections,
the American elections,
and I had to stay up
very late at night
because of the difference
of the time zone.
And what I couldn't understand--
I couldn't understand
this situation.
Because I still remember how the
polls went so terribly wrong.
And then, when I saw that
Florida was lost, I said,
I'm going to bed.
I don't want to know anything.
So I went to bed, and I
saw the disaster that came.
But the inaugural speech
was important for me,
because we wanted to finish the
book with the inaugural speech
of the new president.
And we thought about
Hillary, of course,
because we wanted to have
his husband at the beginning
and her at the end, so-- and
see how everything has changed
after so many years, how
globalization has changed,
if anybody had to say something
about the disaster that
came for many people
in the Western world.
And then we found with Trump--
and I don't know.
Maybe for you--
I'm sure for you if it was even
more incredible than for me.
But seeing President
Obama with this person,
taking him, and helping
him to the podium,
and it was terrible.
And the inaugural speech
was full of the things
that we wrote in the book.
Because one of the problems
that we had with Trump
was that a lot of
things that he said--
and then he will never be
able to maintain, of course--
there were something
that could have been used
in Italy to stop the disaster.
I'm not talking about America
First, because Italy First is
even funny to say.
Because we don't--
we are exporters.
We are net exporters.
We live on export.
And so whenever we say that we
want to close a market, for us,
it would be a disaster.
So you have the inauguration
speech, and we said--
we heard what he said.
We said, let's cancel the book.
We don't want to be-- we
don't want anybody to think
that we agree with this person.
And we were about to sell it.
But then, we were
able to understand
how the problem with
globalization is not--
it's not even the
election of Trump.
It's something so much
bigger that maybe--
that should have been
a different approach
since the beginning.
Because I'm sure that we
all believe in open markets.
We all believe in free trade.
But then, we also
have to understand
that, for example, there is
a lot of the quality of life
that you risk to lose whenever
you buy the cheapest good.
This idea of the
cheapest good to buy
is something we should
really should think about.
Because there is an
underside to that.
When you spend less
money for something,
you spend less money in
a quality of the thing.
And the quality of the things
you buy, you wear, you use
is very important not only
for the general market
but even for yourself.
Because if you dress
bad, you will live bad.
If you buy something that
is not any good quality,
then even your life will
be affected by that.
And we should have
been discussing this
before starting the process.
INTERVIEWER: So that brings to--
a little bit back to Europe.
The euro-- so there
is a great description
in the book of like, well,
what the euro and what
getting into Europe meant for
all the different countries.
And I really enjoyed the
contrast between the Southern
and the Northern Europe.
What should we have done
there-- not get in, negotiate
better condition?
Shall we get out now?
EDOARDO NESI: No, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
That would be the final--
the final straw for us.
No.
I've never been
against the euro.
I think it's
extremely important.
Maybe we should--
well, think about this.
I mean, you take European
countries, which are completely
different one from the other,
and you put all of them
together.
And you give them
a single currency.
And then you start to realize
that, for example, Greece
didn't say the truth
on the declaration
when it got into Europe.
I mean, their balance
sheet was not correct.
They had been falsified.
So the speculation,
let's call it like this--
Guido wouldn't like it, but
let's call it the speculation.
They started to assault Greece
and after Greece, Italy.
And so we said, we are Europe.
I mean, the Central Bank
of Europe will save us.
It didn't happen like this.
The Germans said,
we are not going
to spend money to save Greece.
That's a country that has
been corrupt for centuries.
And the same thing
they said about us.
The interests of these two
countries are too different.
So it's a very difficult--
how would you say--
it's a very difficult
system to stand inside.
And so the interests
are different.
The politics are different.
The countries are different.
Germany is so strong and so good
and so perfectly administered.
And Italy doesn't have the
chance to stand up to this.
So until they will
keep us in the euro,
I would like to stay there.
And I think it's Italy's
interest to be there.
INTERVIEWER: Cool.
I'd like to know if
there's an opening
to question in the
audience, if there is any?
AUDIENCE: Well,
one of the things
I noticed you had commented
on was the large number
of people in parliament
who said had never worked.
And this has also been
an issue in the US.
And one of the kind of
structural reactions to that
was the introduction of
term limits for politicians.
And I don't know if you have
any thoughts on whether you
think that would be a good
thing, a bad thing, if it would
help?
EDOARDO NESI: Well, of
course it would be--
there is-- in
Italy, for example,
in the new parliament, there is
people that have been elected
seven times, eight times.
And they really did nothing to
justify these seven or eight
elections.
But it's a system of power
that perpetuates itself.
And it's something that--
it could be done.
Well, it depends
on how many terms.
Because if you say two terms,
I think it's not enough.
It might be three terms.
But then, when you think
about a political term
here in the United States,
you think about four years.
In Italy, government
can last months.
So whenever there is a
term of a few months,
maybe it's not enough to
state your competence.
So well, yes, I think
there should be a limit.
And even, I mean, you have
here a two terms limit
for a president, for example.
In Italy, you had people that
had been president of the--
well, [INAUDIBLE],, let's
say for three, four times.
And I think it--
yes.
Yes, I think I would support it.
AUDIENCE: What do you think is
the hope for the middle class?
What things can the private
sector and government
do to preserve the essential
role of middle class
in democracy?
EDOARDO NESI: Well, this is the
question, the most important
one.
Let me just tell
you a brief story.
I mean, one of the reasons why I
said that Italy was a fantastic
country was that for,
let's say, 50 years,
the idea that you call the
American Dream was also
the Italian Dream.
But it was even more.
Because think about this.
We have a South of Italy, which
is in a very bad situation
since ever.
And we had a huge immigration
from Campania from the South,
to--
even to Prato, to my hometown.
And they came there.
And they started to work
as ordinary workers.
And then they started to
buy one loom, two looms.
And they started to
become entrepreneurs.
And this system, this idea
that your destiny was not
already written was as an
extremely strong motivation
for the people.
And in Italy, we
used to say-- well,
Prato was one of
the centers of this.
I mean, if you study,
if you work hard,
then you will make money.
And this is a fundamental
promise for middle class.
Because you be-- well, you
enter the middle class.
If you think about it, Italy
had not a big middle class
after the war.
You had very rich people,
and you had very poor people.
And then you started to create
a middle class with this,
with work, with
people that started
to work in the private
sector and started
to work in banks and in
services and in industry.
And there was a
creation of well-being
that was American, in a way.
And it was funny, because
then always in those times,
the Communist Party was
extremely strong in Italy.
So we had a strong
Communist Party
and a huge economical growth.
I wonder if these things
can, in a way, go together.
But that was very,
very interesting.
And then we had a
fantastic growth,
and the middle class
had started to emerge.
But the problem is that
this middle class never
asked for a better politics.
They kept on voting for
the same party, which
was called Christian Democracy,
for many, many, many years.
And they never asked
for something better.
They were too busy
trying to make money.
This is one of the problems.
But what can be done
now, it's very difficult.
Because you could not grow up--
well, the startup-- the startup
phenomenon in Italy is coming.
I mean, it's important.
But not even one of these
startup is labor intensive.
All of them, they need one,
two persons, and that's all.
My company had 40
people working all day.
And then, Prato had the
system that production
could be made by many
other people that
were working for you.
And this is a
contradiction of what
the general economic
theory says.
It's saying you have to unite
everything, all your production
under your single--
after-- in your company, so
you keep things under control.
And what happened in Prato
was that everything was given
freely to the other people.
You could have just an
office and a telephone.
Then, somebody was going
to spin the wool and make--
and then you can have
somebody weave it for you,
somebody dying it for you,
somebody finishing it for you.
And then you had your product,
and you were selling it.
And the quality was
fantastic in every step,
because the private people that
we're working for everybody,
they were-- they
had to be very good.
Otherwise, they wouldn't work.
So the system was
working perfectly.
And that was creating
middle class.
Because you have people from
the South that had nothing.
And then, in 10
years, they had--
they had a house, because there
was a banking system there.
And money was given freely--
maybe too freely but not so
much, not so much.
Until the 1990, money was
given with a certain ease,
but it helped a lot.
So what can be done now?
Frankly, I don't know.
I don't have a lot
of hope on this.
But coming here to
California, for example,
I've been here two days,
so I saw almost nothing.
But I started to recognize some
signs of an economic growth.
And that was
accelerating for me.
It was really--
I was-- seeing people that work
hard to make money and really
make money, it's
exhilarating for me.
It's a throwback to my past.
So it was nice to be here.
AUDIENCE: So here
at Google, and I
think in the tech
industry in general,
we talk a lot about access
and building for everybody.
But on the converse,
in your book
and in the media in general, you
hear a lot about this problem,
in particular the economic
divide increasing over a span
that we'd also associate with
a technological improvement
or an increase in access.
Do you think the
tech industry is
helping mitigate the problem?
Is it improving this
issue, slowing it down?
Or is it accelerating it?
EDOARDO NESI: This is
a very good question.
It might help.
It might help more, also.
Because this is one of the--
the relationship with technology
was one of the problem for Italy
and for textile, for example.
Textile is one of
the industry where
working with a loom that
is 30 years old or three
years old, if you have to weave
wool, is more or less the same.
And this terrible.
Because if you cannot count
on the help of technology,
[INAUDIBLE].
Well, then somebody can take
your business very easily.
For some fibers,
for example, it's
even better if you work
it with very old looms.
There are not many
successful companies--
textile companies now in Prato.
But one which is very
successful, and they make--
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
INTERVIEWER: Scarf.
EDOARDO NESI: Scarves.
Scarves.
They are actually
friends of mine.
They make scarves with the most
beautiful and fine cashmere
in the world.
But they weave the scarves
with hand looms, by hand.
And they have people--
sometimes they are
old ladies that
know everything about this.
And they work with a hand loom.
And if it takes one month to
make a scarf, then it's OK.
And they sell it for 500 euros
a part-- a scarf, a part,
and it's OK.
So this is one of the direction
we could go, and we are going.
But it doesn't help
to hire people.
And that, I think,
is a huge problem.
When technology can not
help you, you don't have--
you don't have a
great hope for future.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious about
the "Dances" in the title.
Where does that come from?
EDOARDO NESI: Oh, it comes from
The Doors, from-- the title,
you mean.
INTERVIEWER: The title, yeah.
EDOARDO NESI:
"Everything is broken up
and dances" is a verse by
Jim Morrison of The Doors.
And being here in Venice
today, I thought that how funny
to think that everything
starts and finishes here.
Because he was working here.
And he was playing here.
And so probably he made
the poem here in Venice.
And we are here
talking about him.
Well, the idea is that I
always loved The Doors.
But then also the poetry of
Jim Morrison, I read all of it.
And these particular
verses, I think,
is perfect to
summarize how things
are becoming increasingly
difficult for my country.
We really feel that everything
is breaking up and dances,
because it's always in
a constant movement.
And we cannot keep it still.
INTERVIEWER: Thank
you very much.
We want to thank Edoardo Nesi
for being here with us today.
EDOARDO NESI: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]